excellent now to call this you know
problems involving civil interest and
not just simple interest okay when
you're having a look at exercise to a
all you're ever working out was the
interest and we use the formula do you
remember what the formula was my equals
good or alternately PRT same idea this
is about a number of years it's a time
period okay now every time it excites to
a they would give you some variety of
principal and the rate and how long it
was going to be in there you always just
have to work out what's the interest
okay so problems involving simple
interest they do two things and maybe
you want to jot these down underneath
okay this is what's gonna be different
from last time number one you have to
find you have to solve for other things
okay
you have to find other values for
instance they'll say instead of work out
the interests right now say look I want
to earn a certain amount of interest
maybe five hundred dollars and I've got
this amount of principal the missing
interest rate so how long must I stay my
must I keep my own my money in there
right yeah we'll talk about I'll give
you some examples in a minute or
alternatively you know I want to this
about an interest I've got this amount
of money and I can do it for five years
what kind of interest rate will I need
to find okay so you can see it's still
using it's still based off this formula
but they're trying to find other values
different things in the picture okay
secondly they introduced the idea of
repayments okay so for instance suppose
you worked out a question it was like
you know how much interest is is going
to earn over five years and you worked
out the X was maybe a thousand dollars
okay now perhaps you want to pay that
all off in one hit just wait to the end
that's a dollars off you go okay but
much more frequently we like to repay in
small chunks right it sort of works
better for most people's budgeting right
so repents that often also called
installments those are
onwards to have in your head okay it
means that we're trying to pay off this
debt well someone else is trying to pay
off a debt to us and you're doing it in
small chunks okay we're gonna work out
what those are so let's have a look at
some examples
let's do doo doo doo doo doo doo
okay page 49 actually if you want to go
back a little bit word example 3 let's
just look at the bold pot the question
read together and then we'll have a go
Anthony invested $1,000 okay sorry this
is I'm looking at page 49 and I'm
looking at worth example 3 maybe I'll
call it 3 now as I read the question and
as you read the question we should note
down the important information so I've
already said Anthony invested a thousand
dollars so I'm going to write that down
a thousand dollars okay always good to
get the facts down as we go at a simple
interest rate of 4.6% interest now they
haven't said you know how often it's
calculated what would you assume would
be how frequently it happens per day per
month per annum probably okay now there
is that interest rate for how long must
he invest in order to earn a hundred
dollars in interest okay he once was one
hundred dollars interest
okay so just like before I'm going to
start with this formula and I'm gonna
fit stuff into it until I can work out
what I want okay so I'm gonna go like
this I equal now what do I know
do I know the interest yes yes I do it's
gonna be $100 this air conditioners on
let's hate I was like I thought I got a
wall right on the front of anyway I
can't we know the interest it's $100 so
I'm gonna put that in right away 100
over here
Pierce our principal do I know how much
money he starts off with how much is
invested and it's a thousand good so you
can see that there
what's the rate it's four point six
percent but you guys know at this point
you know it has to be as a nod percent
it has to be a decimal doesn't it what's
four point six percent as a decimal
good because 0.046 once you start to
practices you start to get into hit
right not 0.46 now then we have an M
right I have an end why is there an end
floating around we're not used to that
usually why is it there what's the
question again the question says for how
long must he invest right so in other
words which we defined out what it is we
don't know what is that's the point of
the question okay so an is unknown we're
gonna work it out in a second okay now I
could work out what this is with a
calculator I could simplify that right
but I kind of don't really need to I can
go straight to the answer I'll show you
how okay see how we have we've got an
equation here right way to solve for n
we had a look at some simple equations
last week when we were doing that skills
review for this topic we looked at
things like this 5x equals 100 okay yeah
if we want X on its own what do we do
sighs I am gonna divine because this
thing is times five so I want to divide
by five to undo that okay so if I divide
this by 5 I divide this by 5 sad okay
how'd you get x equals 20 well done okay
good so is how you do that right I'm
gonna do exactly the same thing here
it's just a bit messier right watch I
don't have one X here I have five that's
too many
okay so I get rid of some of them like
this I just went in on its own but I've
got all this extra fluff right so in
order to get rid of it on this side just
like here I'm gonna do fine I'm going to
divide by 1,000 times 0.04 six okay now
if I do it on that side I should do it
to the other side as well everything you
do to one side equation you're going to
do the other keep your balance right so
I divide this side also by 1,000 now
think back to your fractions on this
right hand side you've got this on the
numerator and you've got exactly the
same thing on the denominator so what
happens to the fraction it just this
cancels doesn't it all just vanishes
right so you lose this you lose this you
just had n on this side right so let me
write that out neatly for you N equals
this
now before you reach for your calculator
even though some of you probably already
have okay I just want to make this as
easy as I can to calculate less numbers
is better there's some really easy stuff
you can sorry that you can see to cancel
up here right see I've got a hundred and
I've got a thousand yeah so every time I
see a zero on the top and the bottom I
can cancel okay Q see that so for
instance here's one cancel on the top so
cancel on the bottom alright
cancel on the top okay it's on the
bottom okay and that's it I'm done
that's that's all the things I can
cancel so what I'm actually putting into
my calculator is this one divided by
that okay what do we get
what does n actually equal
I'm gonna we're getting decimal right
well they won one seven two point one
seven probably some other numbers after
that right yeah okay now did they ask us
for how long now this is tricky they
haven't given us my pedo they don't
explain what units they wanted to vacate
so if I just stopped here what what's
any is that days online so you lose how
do I know it's yes it is he is how do
you know be back I did I did Tori
attention to this before where's my rent
there's something else that's in years
in the question that should tell you
right what else is in years
ah the per annum I do you remember I
asked you about this because the
question didn't say so I said what's it
likely to me it is likely to be per
annum
if the interest is per annum then this
tiny the all has to be animals ears okay
so this is per year this is years that's
why I know this is years okay so that's
kind of the answer but we can do a
little better can't we okay um we
usually talk in we don't generally say
Oh that'll take point one seven years we
would say two years and some number of
months so how do I work this out if it
is roughly two years can I be specific
about how many months it is how I work
it out how many months are there a year
there are twelve months so I would say
twelve months and I just want to work
out how much this pot is that 0.17 right
so if I say multiply that by point one
seven of a year okay that should give me
some number of months right what do you
get thirty wait what
oh you mean including the two years yeah
I just looked this bit on its own the
point one seven two point is that right
it is two points I didn't expect for
though it's okay I think 2.0 is close
enough it is pretty close to two months
isn't it it's a bit less than a fifth of
a year okay so I can say or at this
point I'll say therefore it's two years
and for three months approximately now
I've got a question for you you know how
I stopped here and I said odds a bit
weird to say 0.17 like to turn that bit
into months and that's what I did here
but we've also got part of a month you
why don't I turn the parts of a month in
two days any suggestions yeah
okay this is the first thing it's just
it's a very small amount of time
who cares one day or two days here there
that's a fair point
another thing you want to mention it is
never a transition from being here to
here
I said look how many months in a year
and you said twelve right well fight
with the next step and said how many
days in a month
ah you can't answer me neither can I
because you have no how many days are
there all different right souther 30 so
I'm 31 and there's just one we know
who's got 28 poor my you know wife ever
he has 28 days by the way do you know
December might as well do it now there
are some names either important
particularly these ones October and
December
what does acht or foredeck mean usually
they mean age of 10
why are they the tenth and 12 months hmm
why why is the month which looks like it
should be number eight the tenth month
and why is the month that looks like it
should be number ten the twelfth month
I'll tell you why
Romans is why these days is that this
guy no I'm I'm deadly serious July and
August July and August they're named
after Roman emperors namely Julius
Caesar and Augustus Caesar now here's
the thing right here's why there was
some not only did they screw over this
idea we had a nice decimal calendar ten
months that was nice they screwed that
up and they made it 12 but they also
kept we're emperors we don't want like a
whizbee you know 30-day month that's
that's fur that's a second rate right we
need 31 days in July and August we need
to have big months cuz we're Emperor's
Empress don't have good ones but they're
not meant to thirty
days right why are you two consecutive
months have 31 days of the only ones did
you know so where do you think they got
them from they stolen from February
right that's what every well now that's
a good question why February I'm not
sure why that was like why not why not
may or April sign that but I do know
that's where the two days web and we
have been suffering ever since okay
anyway they go it is it is really me let
me just rewind what do we do and they
didn't like you I hate that favorite guy
anyway we had to work out the number
right of years so we did that we got
down to this no mind then we simplified
a little bit to get number of months as
well okay